this right here is the world's first AI
tablet with a 3D display the Leia
loompad 2 which is able to create
unlimited 3D content for you to view on
its 3D display by using AI to
automatically convert photos and videos
like actual YouTube videos into a 3D
format in just seconds and yes it
actually works very well just like 3D
movie theaters but without any glasses
or accessories at all it's even the
first tablet that comes with a stable
diffusion AI app which also works in 3D
and you can even adjust the 3D depth
using a slider on the side or simply
turn it back on to 2D with the Press of
a button to use it like a regular tablet
that's jam-packed with Flagship specs
like a Snapdragon 888 chip Android 12
and it even comes with 3D light field
cameras on both the front and the back
so you can take 3D Selfies or even 3D
video chat so check it out using the
link in the description